[Musique]
quand vous tombez sur un mot que vous ne
connaissez pas
un sifflez lui vos propres émotions
[Musique]
vous savez les poètes sont les uns
surjets de la logique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en ce temps là
la reine
en l'attente des rives
1000 oiseaux
[Musique]
et ne plissez nulle Spino stral les
neiges vivent en la paille des mers le
ciel pouvait ses jars
songeuse
elle a vivait les feux de lycopode
les saunailles de sable à ses chevilles
bleues
[Musique]
et la rue chancestrale au base des dieux
et tout bien de l'épouse au mystique
rapson aurait et cette baie pour la pure
une nacelle ton sein pour ma naissance
et le psaume des contes
pour le miel le plus vert des mains
mon colocase
[Musique]
et les huttes encore en le bois solennel
soit ta longue patience au fil des
millénaires et sont viennent l'élu par
la houle et carlate
[Musique]
Lune Noire ma peine au loin au loin les
voiles
[Musique]
les sixtre de l'Iran et les races
nouvelles
[Musique]
leurs débouquements des selles du Ponant
donnant au vent d'apocalypse
patemare malévole et mer professionnel
[Musique]
S
et mirage trahi au trouble des marines
et mon âme pleurant aussi de l'exil
rare Yann
et les dodos de morgabine
[Applaudissements]
en ce temps-là la reine en latente des
rires
[Musique]
les neiges vivent on l'a pas eu des mers
le ciel pouvait ses genres
songeuse elle a visé les feux de
l'hippopot
les saunailles de sable asséché du bleu
et la ruche ancestrale au Béa et des
dieux et tout bien de l'épouse au
mystique
pour la pure nacelle ton sombre manie
sens et le psaume des comptes pour le
miel le plus vert des mains mon colocase
et les huttes encore on le boit
solennelle
soit ta langue patience au fil des
millénaires et sans viennent les lieux
par la houle écarlate l'une noire ma
peine au loin au loin les voiles
puissent de l'errance et les races
nouvelles
lors au début que ment des stèles du
Ponant couleur grises donnant au vent
d'apocalypse pattemare malévole et mère
professionnel
l'or fut grand nombre chute sur les
trocs fragiles et mirage trahis aux
troubles des marines et mon âme pleurant
aussi me de l'exil
raré Ariane et les dodo de morgabine
[Musique]
alors il est pas là Boris gamalia mais
on pourrait quand même merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]